du hast Lust deine Hände in krümelige
Gartenerde zu stecken und ihr eine
richtig leckere Gemüseernte zu entlocken
das klingt nach einem ziemlich guten
Plan und damit dein Garten ja nicht so
oder so verläuft sondern du einen bunten
Erntekorb nach dem anderen in die Küche
trägst zeige ich dir in diesem Video wie
du auch komplett ohne Vorkenntnisse
deinen eigenen kleinen Gemüsegarten
anlegst später im Video sprechen wir
dann auch darüber wie du deine
Gemüsepflanzen vor fiesen Schädlingen
beschützt und was du unbedingt über die
Düngung deiner Pflanzen wissen solltest
damit sie überhaupt die Chance haben
groß und kräftig zu werden aber fangen
wir vorne an mit einem Zettel es gibt
Gemüsepflanzen die ziemlich zimperlich
sind und für die man richtig viel
gärtnerisches Fingerspitzengefühl
braucht und andere Gemüsepflanzen sind
viel Anfänger freundlicher weil sie so
ziemlich jeden Fehler großzügig
verzeihen und die einfachsten
anfängerfreundlichsten Gemüsepflanzen
sind Knoblauch Zucchini Mangold
Topinambur das ist so ein richtig
leckeres Knollengemüse das tolle gelbe
Blüten und dass du auch als Sichtschutz
Pflanzen kannst oder auch Radieschen das
hier ist dein Wunschzettel und da
schreibst du jetzt am besten mal alle
Gemüsepflanzen drauf die in deinem
Garten wachsen sollen natürlich die die
du und deine Familie am liebsten esst
und am besten auch möglichst viele
Anfänger Pflanzen die größten zicken im
Gemüsegarten sind übrigens der Rotkohl
und der Blumenkohl die wird ich
persönlich im ersten Gartenjahr erstmal
auslassen eins ist klar du kannst noch
so viel auf deinen Wunschzettel
schreiben das bringt alles nichts wenn
du nicht weißt wo du deine Pflanzen
anbauen sollst also steht jetzt eine
grundlegende Entscheidung an soll es ein
normales Gartenbeet sein ein Hochbeet
oder willst du im Kübel gerne an wenn du
statt einem Garten einen Balkon hast
dann heißt es natürlich ran an die Kübel
auf dem Balkon solltest du immer darauf
achten dass die Kübel groß genug sind
für die jeweiligen Gemüsepflanzen
außerdem trockenen Töpfe und
Pflanzgefäße viel schneller aus als
gartentete so dass Du darauf achten
solltest regelmäßig zu gießen wenn du im
Sommer dann in Urlaub fahren willst dann
kannst du dir z.B aus einer
Wasserflasche automatische Bewässerung
bauen so dass deine grünen Lieblinge
nach dem Urlaub auch genauso frisch und
erholt aussehen wie du im Gemüsegarten
hast du die Wahl zwischen ebenerdigen
normalen Garten beten und Hochbeeten
Hochbeete sind rückenfreundlicher
außerdem bist du unabhängig davon wie
gut dein Gartenboden ist weil du die ja
mit guter Erde auffüllen kannst aber
Hochbeete aufzubauen ist viel teurer und
aufwendiger als einfach ein ebenerdiges
Bild anzulegen und außerdem trockenen
Hochbeete auch viel schneller aus
deswegen musst du einfach abwägen was
die hier wichtiger ist aber in einem
Beet dass du in der falschen Gartenecke
angelegt hast wird das Gemüse niemals so
gut wachsen wie wenn du den richtigen
Standort für deinen zukünftigen
Gemüsegarten auswählst also sprechen wir
als nächstes mal darüber die meisten
Gemüsepflanzen sind nämlich richtige
Sonnenanbeter also beobachte deinen
Balkon oder Garten mal im Tagesverlauf
und such dir einfach die sonnigsten
Flecken für deine Gemüsepflanzen aus es
gibt aber auch ein paar Kandidaten die
lieber im Lidschatten chillen die Blende
ich dir hier Einfalls den Garten eher
schattig ist wichtig ist dass alle
Gemüsepflanzen wenigstens ein paar
Stunden am Tag direkte Sonnenlicht
brauchen im vorschatten könntest du aber
immer noch Pilze anbauen oder ganz
eventuell auch Feldsalat aber dann hört
es mit den Gemüsepflanzen die da wachsen
können auf wenn du in ebenerdigen
beetengärten möchtest dann schau dir
auch mal den Boden an bevor du
entscheidest wo die Beete hinkommen ein
guter Gartenboden ist schön fein
krümelig und nicht zu fest verdichtet
und deine stören die Gemüsepflanzen beim
Wurzeln deswegen solltest du die vorher
absammeln was die gemüsepflänzchen auch
nicht mögen sind starke Winde weil die
können den ganz schön zu schaffen machen
deswegen sollte dein Gemüsegarten immer
irgendwie um Frieden sein so dass der
Wind gebrochen wird das können z.B
hacken oder Zäune sein die den Wind
brechen aber Häuser sind zum Beispiel
auch gute windbrecher und dann wäre es
auch gut wenn du deine Beete auf einer
Fläche anlegst die möglichst eben ist
aber und das ist ganz wichtig die
wenigsten Gärten sind perfekt trotzdem
Gemüseanbau geeignet also macht ihr
keinen Stress wenn du bei dir nicht die
idealen Bedingungen vorfindest und mach
einfach das Beste aus dem was du hast
wenn dein Boden super steinig ist dann
kannst du zum Beispiel statt ebenerdigen
beten auch einfach Hochbeete anlegen und
wenn du einen Hanggrundstück hast dann
musst du das im Zweifel einfach
therassieren bevor du dein Gemüse
anbauen kannst meine Erfahrung nach sind
zwei bis zehn Quadratmeter Beet Fläche
für das erste Garten ja eine richtig
gute Hausnummer aber wer sich mehr
zutraut nur zu ich habe eine Schritt für
Schritt Anleitung erstellt wie man ganz
einfach und schnell direkt auf der Wiese
neue Beta anlegt die Anleitung findest
du in meinem Gemüsegarten Bootcamp das
ist so ein kleiner Gemüsegarten
Crashkurs den ich für meine Newsletter
Abonnenten erstellt habe das ganze
kostet dich kein Geld und ich finde dir
den Link einfach im obersten angepinnten
Kommentar an dann kannst Du da gerne
mitmachen und bekommst da jede Menge
Starthilfe für dein erstes Garten ja mit
ganz vielen Gleichgesinnten Anfänger
Gärtnerinnen und Gärten an und damit für
unsere Beete auch bestücken können
müssen als nächstes natürlich die
Pflanzen her du kannst entweder
Gemüsepflanzen im Haus in kleine
Töpfchen aussäen und erst später im Jahr
nach draußen Pflanzen oder du säßt die
Samen direkt im Beat aus es gibt
wärmeliebende Pflanzen wie Tomaten die
solltest du erst nach dem 15 Mai nach
draußen umziehen also nach den
Eisheiligen weil sie bei niedrigeren
Temperaturen erfrieren könnten dazu
zählen zum Beispiel auch die Paprika die
Aubergine oder die Gurke diese
Kandidaten solltest du also unbedingt
früher im Jahr im Haus aussehen damit
sie vorher Mitte Mai schon in
Wachstumsvorsprung haben weil wenn du
die erst Mitte Mai direkt in Speed sehen
würdest dann würde es ziemlich knapp
werden mit der Ernte andere Pflanzen wie
z.B den cool oder den Salat kannst du
entweder im Haus vorziehen oder direkt
ins Beet sein weil sie schnell genug
wachsen um auch ohne den
Wachstumsvorsprung im Beet rechtzeitig
Ernte reif zu werden sowohl cool als
auch Salat stecken außerdem Frost ganz
gut weg so dass du sie auch schon früher
im Jahr draußen bauen kannst du kannst
sogar im Winter Gemüse anbauen zwar
nicht solche Frostbeulen wie die Tomaten
aber zum Beispiel den Lauch Rosenkohl
Feldsalat Knoblauch Spinat Karotten
einige Salate Pastinaken und noch ganz
viele andere Gemüsepflanzen sind richtig
frosthart und es gibt kein besseres
Gefühl als wenn man am Weihnachtstag ein
Essen aus dem eigenen Garten auf tischt
aber bevor wir ernten können müssen wir
natürlich erstmal sehen und Pflanzen und
wenn du im Haus Jungpflänzchen
vorgezogen hast und die dann in die
Beete umziehen sollen dann musst du sie
davor erstmal abhärten das bedeutet dass
du deine Pflanzen Schritt für Schritt an
die kühleren Temperaturen und an das
Tageslicht gewöhnst weil im Haus stehen
sie ja relativ warm und geschützt und
haben noch nie Wind und Sonne auf ihrem
zarten Blättchen gespürt und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass wir die Pflanzen
tagsüber erstmal für ein paar Stunden
nach draußen stellen und dann wieder
nach drehen dann können Sie am nächsten
Tag schon ein bisschen länger draußen
bleiben vielleicht auch mal das erste
Mal in der direkten Sonne stehen
und dann kommen sie wieder nach Tränen
und so kannst du dann deine
Jungpflänzchen nach und nach über den
Zeitraum von ungefähr einer Woche an das
wilde raue draußen Leben gewöhnen bevor
sie dann wirklich nach draußen in Speed
umziehen können übrigens sind oft auch
die Pflanzen die man im Gartencenter
oder im Baumarkt kauft nicht an das
draußen Leben gewöhnt so dass du auch
diese Pflanzen oft noch zu Hause
abhärten muss und sobald du deine Gemüse
Kinder dann in die Freiheit entlassen
hast sind sie ja eine Reihe von
Schädlingen ausgeliefert die die
Pflänzchen am liebsten aufessen wollen
bevor du sie aufessen kannst und
wahrscheinlich die ersten Schädlinge mit
denen du Bekanntschaft machen willst
sind Schnecken schnecken können ein
ganzes Gemüsebeet innerhalb von einer
Nacht komplett abfressen hier müssen wir
also was unternehmen was gut hilft ist
nachts mit der Taschenlampe bewaffnet
durch die Beete zu streifen und einfach
alle Schnecken abzusammeln die man sieht
nachts kommen die nämlich aus ihren
Verstecken gekrochen um mir Unheil
anzurichten und dann kann man
massenweise Schnecken absammeln aber
gerade cool und Salat solltest du im
Jungpflanzenstadium immer zusätzlich mit
einem schneckenring Schützen den stülpst
du einfach über die Pflanze drüber und
drückst ihn ein paar Zentimeter in den
Boden und dieser umgeknickte Rand hier
kann von Schnecken nämlich nicht
überwunden werden und für manche
Schnecken kriegen gibt es sogar
sogenannte Treibhaus Deckel die kannst
du einfach oben aufsetzen und so kannst
du dann den schneckenring auch noch in
ein kleines Mini Gewächshaus verwandeln
so dass die Pflanzen außerdem noch viel
schneller wachsen und nicht einknicken
falls doch noch mal eine Temperatursturz
kommt sobald die Pflänzchen dann größer
sind stecken sie in den schneckenbesuch
besser weg und dann kannst du den
schneckenring einfach abnehmen und für
deine nächsten Jungpflanzen verwenden
ein anderer richtig fieser Schädling ist
der cool Weißling ein wunderschöner
Schmetterling aber die Raupen snacken
nichts lieber als Kohlrabi Weißkohl
Rotkohl Blumenkohl Brokkoli Rosenkohl
Spitzkohl und Wirsing und sind nicht
besonders erpicht darauf dir was übrig
zu lassen also sperren wir die am besten
von vornherein aus und decken die
entsprechenden Beete mit einem
sogenannten kulturschutznetz ab das ist
wirklich die einfachste und
ökologischste Möglichkeit um deine
Pflanzen vor den Raupen zu schützen ohne
giftige Pestizide sprühen zu müssen und
dafür kannst du entweder Bögen aus
elektroinstallationsrohren aus dem
Baumarkt bauen und die Kultur
Schutznetze dann darüber spannen wie so
ein kleiner Tunnel sie das dann aus oder
du legst die kulturschützen jetzt
einfach ohne Bögen direkt auf deine
Pflanzen das kannst du machen wie du es
am schönsten findest hauptsache du
beschwerst die Netze einfach mit so
vielen Steinen dass sie nicht wegfliegen
können die schneckenringe und auch die
Kultur schützen Netze findest du
übrigens und unter Wurzelwerk minus
shop.com unserem nigelnagelneuen Shop
und den Link findest du auch in der
Videobeschreibung wir haben unsere
Pflänzchen jetzt also gut beschützt
jetzt müssen wir sie nur noch gut
füttern und zwar mit dünner
unterschiedliche Gemüsepflanzen haben
den ganz unterschiedlichen
Nährstoffbedarf meine unterscheidet die
Gemüsepflanzen in drei Gruppen die
starken das sind die ganz hungrigen die
mittelslehrer sind mittelhungrig und die
schwachzierer brauchen eigentlich
überhaupt keine zusätzliche Düngung und
vor allem den stark Ceran gebe ich beim
Pflanzen ein Dünger direkt ins
Pflanzloch einen festen Dünger der sich
nach und nach auflöst dafür kann man
entweder den Klee Dünger verwenden oder
Hornspäne oder Schafs wollpellets die
Dosierung ist je nach Dünger Hersteller
natürlich unterschiedlich aber das ist
immer auf der Packung mit angegeben und
in der Saison sollten vor allem die
Starkzehrer auch noch regelmäßig
Nährstoffe über das Gießwasser bekommen
der Unterschied ist dass wenn man über
das Gießwasser mit einem Flüssigdünger
düngt dass der sofort für die Pflanzen
verfügbar ist das mache ich bei den
starken alle paar Wochen bei den Mädels
Lehrern vielleicht einmal pro Saison und
dafür verwende ich am liebsten wie nasse
die wird aus Resten der Zucker
Herstellung verwendet ich finde es super
wichtig dass man nur biologische
organische Dinger verwendet und keine
Kunst weil die Herstellung von
Kunstdüngern unfassbar energieaufwendig
ist und man in dem Gemüsegarten super
einfach auf Kunstdünger verzichten kann
und die Biodünger die ich euch hier
aufgelistet habe sind alle super
wirkungsstark und funktionieren richtig
gut ein Thema das mir super arg am
Herzen liegt aber mit dem ich euch im
ersten Garten ja nicht unbedingt direkt
überfallen möchte ist die Anbauplanung
also welches Gemüse wächst neben welchem
Gemüse wie sehr ich so aus dass ich rund
ums Jahr ernten kann also welche aussah
Zeitpunkte sind die besten wie gestalte
ich eine Fruchtfolge so dass ich die
mädelsehera vielleicht gar nicht mehr
düngen muss und deswegen habe ich einen
fertig ausgeklügelten beet-plan den ihr
euch gerne herunterladen könnt den
verlinke ich euch auch in der
Videobeschreibung und da habe ich alles
für euch vorgefertigt damit ihr im
ersten Jahr erstmal einfach losgegangen
könnt und euch darum keinen Kopf machen
müsst wenn euch das interessiert findet
ihr aber hier drüben noch ein Video wo
ich euch die an Bauplanung ganz genau
erkläre und dann geht raus gerettet los
und macht die Welt ein bisschen grüner
und wir sehen uns im nächsten Video
wieder bis dann tschüss